avec ce recueil les voici incollable sur
le monde ses vingt-cinq élèves de ce1 de
l'école alain cavalier ou longuement
travaillé sur les pays
ça les a fait grandir ça leur a ouvert
l'esprit
alors effectivement on demande beaucoup
aux enfants de découvrir le monde le
monde qui les entoure mais bon le monde
un petit peu plus lointain c'est un
petit peu abstrait pour eux donc grâce à
ça c'était concret comprenait quelques
petites notes on a été aussi faire
quelques petites recherches sur les
tablettes
ça nous a permis un petit peu de trouver
des photos pour ajouté il ya des
traditions
il ya des animaux typique et à des plats
traditionnels ya aussi des fêtes
traditionnelles tout ce que nous avons
posé comme question elle les a marqués
et les réponses que nos blocs trotteurs
en fait il les a marqués aussi les globe
trotteurs se sont florian et antoine
deux étudiants partis autour du monde
depuis le mois d'octobre
ils échangent régulièrement par vidéo et
par mail a pas déjà pour les beaux
paysages en est plutôt bien là on est au
sud de l'afrique du sud est on est juste
une deuxième place un suivi leur voyage
les cm 1 et cm 2 e ou choisi de créer un
roman d'aventurés en basin par ces
tunnels sous marin fluffy de terribles
megalodon diabolique avait nagé jusqu'à
l'un de ses repères situés en afrique
ka-shing un travail d'imagination et de
france et une heure par semaine
il conte les histoires de leila miiaou
et fluffy au delà du côté littéraire il
ya eu donc la dimension géographique
il ya eu un côté aussi
ce qu'on appelle chez nous et éducation
morale et civique donc avec le fait de
d'avoir la possibilité de découvrir
culturellement des peuples avec un mode
de vie très différent de celui que
connaissent les enfants attendent
maintenant le retour de florian riz
antoine pour peut-être créer de nouveaux
romans